je suis arrivé ici il y a 12 ans à 10h
10h30 du matin ma caisse d'Avignon était
vendu maintenant ma caisse d'oignon
[Musique]
ils disparaissent lentement mais
sûrement il y avait en France en 1960
200000 cafés il n'en reste plus
aujourd'hui que 70 000 signes des temps
habitude sociale qui change concurrence
acharnée des fast-food il y a quelques
années encore on mangeait à la maison et
on buvait dehors au siècle dernier on
les appelait même les salons de la
démocratie il ferme leur porte
définitivement Pierre Bonte et Michel
Levasseur ont visité quelques-uns des
derniers bistrots français une
disparition dramatique car dans les
campagnes c'est troqué était devenu de
véritables carrefour de communication et
d'échanges
[Musique]
je vais chercher
du village
[Musique]
avenue Montaigne à Paris les essais
étaient l'un des derniers vrais bistrot
de ce quartier riche voué au commerce de
luxe et bien c'est fini il vient de
fermer c'est une boutique de mode une de
plus qui va prendre sa place le patron
n'a pas résisté à la proposition d'un
grand couturier qui a mis 18 millions de
francs sur la table pour obtenir cet
emplacement de 45 m² à ce prix là il n'y
a plus de place pour les bistrots dans
le quartier
il y a économique pour le bistro on peut
survivre à condition d'être sûr de faire
60 couverts par jour en ne vendant que
du caviar blanc à la louche et mes sans
ça on fait un métier qui consiste à
faire des plats du jour à entre 70 et 85
francs pour pouvoir nourrir les gens qui
travaillent autour c'est plus viable je
suis très j'ai vécu des heures
magnifiques ici où je retrouvais des
amis maintenant je ne sais plus où aller
c'était un déchirement pour moi
on aura le choix entre le Plaza Athénée
et l'équipe burgers
Villemomble dans la banlieue parisienne
5h30 du matin comme tous les jours
depuis 20 ans Monsieur Biron fait
l'ouverture de son café tabac face à la
gare à l'heure des premiers trains et
des derniers rêves
d'origine auvergnate comme la majorité
des patrons de café de la région
parisienne monsieur Biron est le
président des cafetiers limonadiers une
profession qui a perdu les deux tiers de
ses membres en 30 ans il y avait 210 000
café en France en 1960 il en reste
environ 70 000 et il en disparaît
régulièrement 3 à 4000 tous les ans les
raisons elles sont très diverses à la
fois économiques et sociologique du fait
de la désertification des zones rurales
chacun de ces beaucoup de commerces
disparaissent et les cafés sont souvent
des premiers touchés je vois dans mon
petit village du Cantin la youthanes il
y avait dans les années 50 6 ou 7 café
il n'en reste plus qu'un aujourd'hui et
qui qui vivent je dirais parce que la
population a beaucoup des milliers
ceci étant dit en zone urbaine ou en
zone périphérique des grandes villes
ce sont surtout les rénovations de
quartier qui font disparaître des
établissements et tel ou tel quartier
d'un arrondissement parisien rénové
c'est la disparition de 10 20 voire 30
ou 40 café qui ne seront remplacés dans
le nouvel urbanisme que par 4 ou 5
établissements
les fast food aussi ont tué beaucoup de
bistrots à Paris et dans toutes les
grandes villes les meilleures
emplacements les cafés d'angle comme on
les appelle ont souvent été rachetés à
prix d'or par les McDo Quick et autres
formes de restauration rapide
et puis surtout les modes de vie ont
changé les jeunes ont pris d'autres
habitudes
les nouvelles sandales
pas bonnes
Robert Henry le patron du Petit Poucet
place Clichy à Paris et né derrière un
comptoir comme il a coutume de dire
puisque ses parents étaient déjà dans le
métier et il a vécu toute cette
évolution du bistrot bien fait de
société avant je vous dis on allait au
café parce qu'on pouvait pas aller
ailleurs maintenant il y a vraiment
milieu d'accueil dans les grandes villes
ça soit les musées les cinémas les T1
bon les gens allaient moins me vendre
maintenant c'est c'est on va tout
naturellement au cinéma avant le cinéma
c'était une sortie bon bah là aussi on a
une concurrence la télévision nous fait
concurrence comment voulez-vous qu'on
lutte nous avec notre sourire quand un
film très bon qui passe le soir à la
télé les gens disent ils regardent le
programme on dit dans ta vie ce soir il
y a ça à la télé tout naturellement
reste chez eux les gens savent leurs
petits whisky de l'armoire un petit
glaçon dedans puis regarde la film bon
on peut pas lutter contre
[Musique]
le type même du café sympathique
accueillant et pas cher c'était
autrefois le bougnat le café bois
charbon il en reste encore trois ou
quatre à Paris où le patron continue de
livrer le charbon à domicile dans les
étages pendant que l'épouse est derrière
le comptoir pour prendre les commandes
et servir à boire mais il en a plus pour
longtemps parce que leur clientèle
vieillit elle aussi
c'est terminé mais bon ça disparaîtra
monsieur on pense à vendre
du matin ma caisse Avignon était vendus
maintenant
[Musique]
que nous pouvons vivre tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours vous avez
vos habitudes
de venir presque tous les jours
et vous buvez toujours la même chose
ça dépend
ils connaissent même les prix faut pas
que je me trompe
tous les jours là
et si je les vois pas bon je téléphone
ou fait des fois
je m'occupe d'eux
pas de problème
si ça disparaît c'est vrai que ça fera
un drôle de trou dans le quartier
à chaque fois qu'un café disparaît c'est
un peu de vie d'un quartier qui qui s'en
va et qui meurt on peut pas vivre sans
café
on peut pas vivre sans établissements où
les gens ont peuvent se retrouver entre
amis
discuter échanger leurs opinions quel
est le lieu le plus propice à un échange
d'idée qu'un comptoir on s'offre une
cigarette on se passe le sucre on se
passe les croissants et de la
conversation s'engage tout naturellement
puis alors on compte pas il y a pas il y
a pas de rédacteur chez nous on se met
au comptoir on y reste une heure et
jamais personne vous dit dis donc elle
s'est vu tu vas prendre l'air et vous
connaissez beaucoup de professions où on
fait plaisir pour quatre francs 80 par
exemple
le café c'est aussi un endroit où on
boit c'est aussi un endroit où on
commence à alcalise à vous même user
avec ça c'est tenace la légende de Zola
de la Somme noire vous y tenez vraiment
mais on ne vient plus chez nous
pourboire la preuve
la part d'alcool que l'on vend dans nos
établissements ça devient signifiant
c'est un ou deux pour cent du chiffre
d'affaires ça compte plus pour nous
l'alcool
d'une manière générale la vente des
boissons alcoolisées ou non est en
baisse dans les cafés et pour compenser
beaucoup ont adopté la formule brasserie
à midi
[Musique]
un gros malaise au niveau concurrence au
niveau comme le mot bistrot par exemple
le mot bistrot veut dire bière café on
vendait que que ça à l'époque de nos
parents et maintenant on est obligé de
faire à manger on est obligé de se
mettre à la page il faut faire beaucoup
de beaucoup à manger dans le temps avec
80 % de limonade et 20% de mangeailles
en arrivée à faire face et maintenant
c'est l'inverse il faut faire 80% de à
manger et 20% de limonade si on veut
s'en sortir pour vous c'est mieux ou
c'est moins bien c'est à dire ça demande
plus de personnel et ça augmente les
frais automatiquement quand limonade pur
avec un garçon on peut faire un chiffre
plus plus grand avec un rapport meilleur
et puis dans cette course à la
rentabilité le bistrot perd souvent son
âme
déjà ils ont ils ont 20 minutes pour
manger et pas une de plus
pour que ce soit bon
faut être compétitif agréable merci
beaucoup pavé de
avant deux heures on est fou
sinon les brasseries
pour l'instant les Auvergnats et leurs
voisins à Véronique sont encore
solidement installés à Paris mais
souvent leurs enfants refusent de
prendre la suite parce qu'ils trouvent
le métier trop dur et les journées trop
longues et ce sont les Kabyles qui
prennent peu à peu leur place
actuellement plus de 30% des cafés de la
région parisienne sont tenus par des
Kabyles monsieur Yaku par exemple a
racheté le bar hôtel de l'Aveyron dans
le sac à arrondissement en 1969 alors on
fait des économies au départ et puis
après il y a des crédits
quand on achète
nous prête comme ça directement
d'ailleurs on commence toujours pour
nous encore la famille de la ville
commence toujours par des toutes petites
affaires et puis au fur et à mesure
il y en a qui ont des très grosses
affaires aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils sont arrivés ils sont
travaillés sans mérités
toujours plein
tu l'ouvrier
[Musique]
à Bordeaux comme ailleurs la plupart des
patrons de bistrot se plaignent et il
regarde avec envie l'extraordinaire
succès du plannat un bar de la place de
la Victoire qui fonctionne
principalement le soir et dans la
formule s'inspire des bodega espagnol le
clientèle de jeunes uniquement débordant
jusque sur le trottoir qui discute
debout jusqu'à 2h du matin en buvant de
la bière ou des perroquets dans des vers
en plastique et dans une musique
assourdissante
[Musique]
quand on vient au planning à Bordeaux
c'est pour la fête en général c'est pour
c'est le début d'une soirée étudiante tu
viens là parce que tu as envie
d'attraper des copains de présenter j'ai
envie de boire un coup de pompe ou trois
ponts et dans l'ambiance
suppléante fait des connaissances entre
gens et après tu sors et on voit
beaucoup on le voit énormément
c'était énormement reproché par les
parents et il faut que vous sachiez que
bordeaux est une ville test pour les
contrôles de l'alcoolémie et que par
aujourd'hui tous les jeudis soirs tous
les vendredi soir il y a des contre
l'alcoolémie énorme contre la joie que
les gens savent que les jeunes voient
énormément
essaie justement d'empêcher cela
d'empêcher les jeunes de prendre le
volant en prenant les contrôles très
strictes autour de la place
[Musique]
une autre formule qui marche très fort
actuellement c'est le pavirlandais comme
celui que vient d'ouvrir à Bordeaux
Vincent Moscato le célèbre joueur de
l'équipe de Bègles Bordeaux
le jour de l'inauguration en tout cas
l'ambiance était très chaude
[Musique]
mes enfants c'est rassurant le bon vieux
café français traditionnel a encore sa
place semble-t-il à quelques mètres du
plana le café chez Auguste qui a vu
défiler plusieurs générations de lycéens
et d'étudiants connais toujours le même
succès auprès des jeunes bordelais bien
que le décor n'est pratiquement pas
changé
si on moderniser tout ça vous y
reviendriez ou pas dans ce café mais
ouais c'est pas les murs qui comptent
c'est à l'intérieur
de style c'est sympa c'est bien moi
j'aime bien ce style classique en plus
il y a des super miroirs moi je trouve
ça magnifique
la propriétaire de chez Auguste de toute
façon madame la bataille n'a pas
l'intention de toucher au
décoraient tendance à être la génération
Coca-Cola ou McDo ils viennent quand
même ici j'ai pas de hamburger j'ai pas
de genre de trucs ils viennent ici
pourquoi parce qu'il y a un lieu de
rencontre et je crois que ça c'est
nécessaire c'est vital et c'est pas une
boîte de Coca-Cola dans la rue qui
l'appartement
le thé c'est encore mieux c'est de l'eau
pour moi
[Musique]
les gros vont tenir
plus difficilement mais en restera mais
c'est vrai que les petits bars de
quartier vont disparaître les petits
bars comme
comme le bord de la marine de Rémus
c'est une époque révolution c'est
dommage parce que c'est tellement génial
de voir ces vieux grand-père derrière
leur comptoir qui avait une façon de
servir le ricard sans la goutte etc ça
ça disparaîtra les barres tels que le
nôtre moi j'ai la chance de me dire
qu'Auguste restera mais c'est Auguste
c'est une institution aussi Auguste
c'est c'est un lieu qui existe
pratiquement depuis 100 ans où tous les
étudiants de Bordeaux sont obligés pour
eux dans la mentalité de passer chez
Auguste donc ça s'explique pas je sais
pas grâce à moi c'est le lieu par
lui-même qui amène ces gens là
campagne la fermeture d'un bistrot a des
conséquences plus graves qu'en ville
parce que le café est souvent le dernier
commerce le dernier lieu de rencontre
dans un village
alors de plus en plus quand le dernier
qu'a fait ferme on voit la commune
racheter le fond et le mettre en girance
libre c'est ce qui a permis par exemple
aux habitants de poil dans la Nièvre de
garder leur café auberge
[Musique]
il y a un petit pays à côté là
c'est mort
imaginez quand vous avez une cérémonie
ou un enterrement ou quelque chose mais
la coutume veut qu'après l'enterrement
par exemple tout le monde aille
tranquille en général si vous avez pas
de café qu'est-ce qui se passe
vous rentrez chacun chez vous il y a pas
de discussion
pourquoi vous venez au café
j'en suis pas privé de rien mais
avec l'accompagnement sur le canon
dans l'Indre le café vient d'être sauvé
de justesse dans ce village berrichon
depuis trois générations les girons sont
à la fois bouchés et cafetiers les deux
commerces sont côte à côte dans le même
immeuble et sont reliés par un couloir
monsieur giron s'occupe de la boucherie
charcuterie tandis que son épouse tient
le café
mais Monsieur et Madame giron ont décidé
de prendre leur retraite prochainement
alors pour maintenir un peu de vie au
village le conseil municipal a racheté
l'immeuble et recherche un jeune couple
pour reprendre leur suite
c'est le rendez-vous
des copains des amis et quand on vient
on passe avec la voiture on voit une
voiture arrêtée on reconnaît la voiture
qui est la partie on lui tient il y a un
tel un tel qu'il est là alors on
s'arrête on boit un verre on vous acide
café disparaître il y aura plus personne
Madame Durand vous qu'est-ce que ça vous
fait de d'abandonner ce café cette
maison
parce que bon c'est une chose qui est
plus à refaire c'est fait voilà c'est
définitif
c'est très bien que Monsieur Rico
merveille et le conseil est agit comme
ça je trouve que c'est très bien pour
vivre
parce que vous savez ici le commerce se
fermait le pays était mort complètement
[Musique]
le rachat du café boucherie de veille à
côté 480 mille francs à la commune le
conseil municipal de poils a investi 850
000 francs pour acquérir et remettre au
goût du jour le café auberge c'est
beaucoup pour une petite commune de 230
habitants seulement mais le maire de
poil monsieur conique ne regrette pas
d'avoir été l'un des premiers en France
à municipaliser un café
bon maintenant je me demande même on est
il y a deux communes dans le canton qui
ont pas beaucoup perdu de population on
est dedans on a dans les deux qui ont
pas perdu presque pas perdu de
population je me demande bien si c'est
pas un peu ça grâce au café ben je sais
quand même pu vivre depuis ce temps-là
mais vous croyez que c'est le rôle d'une
commune d'investir dans un café ma biche
oh oui toute façon moi je suis
communiste
l'initiative
c'est tellement important de faire le
café autrement
vous savez moi je pense devant l'auberge
je m'arrête
s'ils sont un deux bon ça va on se
raconte ce qui se passe on discute si on
est 4 ans
[Musique]
on les avait surnommés au 19e siècle les
salons de la démocratie faudra-t-il
aller jusqu'à déclarer les cafés service
public on peut toujours aller en
discuter au bistrot du coin
[Musique]